let's think a little bit about two terms
that you will see throughout your
geometry and really mathematical career
one is the idea of things being
perpendicular and usually people are
talking about perpendicular actually I'm
misspelling it perpendicular
perpendicular lines
normally perpendicular lines and the
idea of parallel lines parallel parallel
lines so perpendicular lines are two
lines that intersect at a right angle so
what am i what am i talking about so
let's say that this is one line right
over here and that this is another line
right over here we would say these two
lines are perpendicular if they
intersect at a right angle so they
clearly intersect in order for them to
intersect at a right angle the angle
formed between these two lines needs to
be 90 degrees and if any one of these
angles is 90 degrees the rest of them
are going to be 90 degrees so this is 90
degrees and these are perpendicular
lines and if that's 90 degrees and
that's going to be 90 degrees that's
going to be 90 degrees and that's going
to be 90 degrees so if any of them are
90 degrees the rest of them are 90
degrees and we have perpendicular lines
if you have two lines that on a
two-dimensional surface like your paper
or like the screen never intersect they
stay the same distance apart then we are
talking about parallel lines so this
line right over here and this line right
over here the way I've drawn them are
parallel lines they aren't intersecting
they're both kind of going in the same
direction but they're in there they're
kind of shifted versions of each other
they will never intersect with each
other so these two are parallel if we
have two lines that let's say they
intersect but they don't intersect at a
right angle so let's say we have that
line and we have this line right over
here and they're clearly not
intersecting at a right angle then we
call these neither perpendicular nor
parallel lines these lines just
intersect